vous veniez moynier légèrement pas une
et poignets là vous êtes bon niveau je
t'annonce à la table trouvé que le bras
de fer est un vrai sport l'objectif de
ce quatrième championnat de france
organisé ce samedi 3 mars dans la
commune de vélizy villacoublay
pour cela deux arbitres assistent au
match et font appliquer des règles
codifiées par les américains au siècle
dernier
on insiste bien sur le terme de bras de
fer sportif pas du bras de fer de
comptoir pour vos poignets soit bien
droit qu'est votre canetons ce soit en
fait que vous ayez l'épaule bien en face
que vous soyez dans l'axé médian de la
table pour que les règles de ce sport
soit entièrement respectée les arbitres
n'hésite pas à lier les participants
j'ai attaché
parce qu'en fait il ya eu un lâcher
d'eau n'ont pas réussi à terminer le
combat entre temps en prison
sur la table la testostérone autour du
biceps ne font pas tout chaque ferry se
doit s'échauffer plusieurs minutes avant
son passage et surtout avoir une
stratégie pour remporter la victoire
intérieur ça veut dire en fait on passe
intérieure en reste groupé et en tire
comme ça et extérieur en utilise la
rotation jugé plus comme ça la force est
au service de la technique et non la
force qui remplace la technique vous
avez des gens qui pour d'autres
disciplines sont des gens très puissants
mais quand vous les mettez sur une tête
de braaten
ils ont un petit niveau de résistance
mais apprennent et non pas la technique
ils ont un peu perdu
cet événement permettra peut-être à
attirer de nouveaux licenciés pour ce
sport encore confidentiel qui compte
seulement 200 pratiquants france et une
trentaine dans les yvelines